- Thank you.
Welcome everybody.
So you know I'm wearing
my agentic shirt today.
Are you all wearing your agentic outfits?
Everybody's agentic.
But I'm gonna actually
present today an actual agent
and actually two agents working together,
which I'm super excited about.
So the AI SRE is all about
solving problems in production, right?
Everybody has observability.
You have all this data,
but you need to solve
problems under pressure
and you have to go through
a lot of data to do that,
so that's the topic today.
We're gonna see how
agents can help analyze
the root cause of issues
and really reduce your mean
time to resolution, right,
by automating the process of
investigating the root cause.
And then I'll show you how you can work
with your coding agent, cloud code cursor,
GitHub, CoPilot, et cetera,
to actually implement the resolution
recommended by our agent
that does the analysis.
This is delivering massive
productivity gains to our customers,
but also reduction of outages,
better system availability
and uptime, right,
and so the impact of
incidents can be very costly
and that's what an agent can do
and that's really driving massive savings.
And one note is that, you know,
our customers are deploying this
without changing any of
their existing tools.
So you keep your observability,
your incident management,
people work with the
tools they're used to,
and here we're having an
agent that's gonna help them.
Okay, so that's just a few examples.
We have a insurance company
that's really, for them,
it's all about reducing
the cost of incidents.
They have a complex
on-prem and AWS footprint
and issues that span those can
be all analyzed by Hawkeye.
Hawkeye is the name of our agent.
The company is called NeuBird.
And Hawkeye can deploy as a
SaaS product or in your VPC.
So if you're a security conscious company
and you want control over your AI,
we can actually deploy
Hawkeye in your VPC.
That's what this insurance
company is doing,
and it's connected to
their on-prem telemetry.
We have a, you know,
shipping and logistics
company where for them
it's all about managing data pipelines,
massive numbers of night jobs
that are running on Databricks
with Flink jobs running on EKS
and they have to make sure
all these end in time, right?
And so for them it's all about, you know,
handling all these alerts that come
off of these data pipelines, nightly jobs.
And the last example
is a bank in Australia
that uses us the first use case,
now they use us across a lot of use cases.
The first use case was as
simple as backup management.
So if you're a bank and
you have a lot of backups,
you need to explain why they're failing
and how you're gonna avoid the
backups from failing again,
because there's regulations around that.
Okay, so those are some quick
examples and really again,
it's about helping this guy, right?
And it's, we call it an AI SRE,
but it's serving the whole company
and usually there's like
an on-call team, right,
that are not maybe the SREs,
but they pull in the
SREs when they don't know
how to solve the problem
and you end up with all these people
sifting through all the information
because you have this
dynamic cloud environment
with lots of layers, lots of
telemetry, lots of alerts,
and then inevitably you have
lots of people jumping on a call.
Have you been on one of
these calls where you know,
like there's 30 people there
and it's interrupting,
your day is stressful,
nobody knows why they're there.
There's finger pointing,
potentially, hopefully not.
So what if you could just have a very
clean explanation of what's going on?
And that's really what we're doing.
We're taking you from a manual workflow
where you have people
logging into Datadog, Splunk,
you know, Grafana, CloudWatch, et cetera,
and doing kind of the mental
work of looking at dashboards
and trying to explain what's going on
to then be able to resolve it.
So we're taking this manual
workflow and automating it
with an agent that can
trigger automatically
connect to your telemetry,
explain exactly what's going on,
and provide a very easy to
read summary for the user.
So anybody wanna see that?
Okay, so this is Hawkeye.
We're looking at a dashboard
and on the left we have
incidents and alerts
that have not been investigated
and on the right we're
seeing incidents and alerts
that have been investigated.
So what I'm gonna do is show you
the information that we're
providing in an alert context.
So you see there's some user initiated
and automated sessions.
So let's just look at this one.
I'm gonna pick one at random.
This one happens to be a Datadog monitor.
I have a tremendous amount of context here
for the agent to work with
because I'm triggering
automatically off of an alert.
Alerts have rich context for
the agent to do the work.
The work happens in the background
and what you're seeing here
can be delivered wherever
the team is working.
It could be on Slack,
it could be on Teams,
it could be in your coding agent,
it could be on ServiceNow.
Basically I think the future is headless.
We have a UI here where you can
kind of consult the information,
but you should be able to
consume this information
no matter where you
work without necessarily
coming to our user interface.
But in here I can kind of see the summary,
the incident description,
the application artifacts,
timeline of events, the evidence,
the root cause and the corrective actions.
Okay, so contrast that
with just the alert,
you know that JSON I showed you, you know,
the in ServiceNow you
might see it represented,
there's some, you know, AI SRE tools
that are just basically
regurgitating that, you know,
summarizing it and
presenting the alert to you,
but what we're doing here
is we're digging deep
into the actual data in
your observability tools,
the traces, the telemetry, the metrics,
the logs, also your config, right,
we can log into your AWS console
and see all the same
data that you see there,
how your security groups are configured,
how your EKS cluster is configured.
We could use Coop CUDL to go
and interrogate the Kubernetes cluster.
So we're doing what an SRE would do to
kind of find a root cause,
not just kind of summarizing
what we're seeing in the alert.
And all this work is available here.
So typically the workflow is
you just get the conclusion,
the corrective actions,
you take those actions
and you close the ticket,
but sometimes you have to dig deeper.
Of course you have kind of
a budget for investigations.
You know, by default we just
go and do what we call one,
you know, prompt cycle.
So here is a chain of
thought and we have like
five or six questions that
we're gonna go through
and to answer each of them
we're gonna consult a
series of data sources.
And you can see here the
full list of data sources
available for this
particular investigation.
There were a lot of them, config, traces,
logs, metrics,
all consulted in order to provide
this very deep and rich analysis.
And so at every step I
have all this analysis
and that is what gets then summarized
in the RCA itself that gets shipped off
to your Slack channel, et cetera.
And something that I'm very excited about
is this new capability
that I'm gonna show you
that we just released which allows you
to work in your coding assistant.
So here I'm showing you
Claude code and you know
I think real SREs they don't like UIs.
That's my kind of theory.
And they work in a shell
and they're really good with scripting
and working in shells.
And if you're that kind of person
and you're looking to
leverage AI to do your work,
I would say go to cloud code.
That should be your first step, right?
I'm sure most of you have
already taken that step.
It's extremely powerful
because it can use all your available
CLI tools that you have on your system.
And then it has this
concept of an MCP server
that you can add to it.
An MCP server stands for
model context protocol.
Think of it as kind of an API that the
L and M can automatically
understand and interrogate,
and it's basically self-documenting
so you can kind of plug in these tools
and you can start plugging
in a bunch of MCP servers,
but at some point the more you plug in
you get diminishing return.
So what we're doing is we're
taking your Datadog connection,
your AWS information, your CICD pipeline,
your GitHub connection, all
that is managed by Hawkeye
and Hawkeye is providing one MCP server
to the coding assistant here
that can basically orchestrate
the whole thing that I showed you earlier,
the whole investigation
can learn over time,
can do all these things,
but now I can kind of talk to
that one MCP server as an SRE
and be like, okay, I want to do things
with this MCP server.
So it's self-documenting.
You can actually ask it,
you know, what do you do?
How can I use this MCP server?
It can help you with
the onboarding process.
You can have, you know, all
these typical workflows,
listing alerts, starting an investigation,
monitor the progress of an investigation,
get results of an investigation.
So I use this extensively
like we do evaluations in POC,
so I can download all root cause analysis
and then run queries
in my coding assistant
across all the RCAs for the last week.
Maybe I'm looking for patterns,
I'm looking for things
that keep happening.
I want to analyze all my alerts
and find, you know,
the thing that I should be actually fixing
as a site reliability engineer.
Our job is not to just fight fires,
it's to prevent them, right?
And with my coding agent
and this deep kind of
analytic capability of Hawkeye that can go
and look at all my telemetry
I can prompt Hawkeye to
do all this deep research,
extract all this information,
and then process this
information in my coding agent.
I can also automate the remediation steps
recommended by Hawkeye.
And so this is what you're seeing here,
a set of things that I go
through normally, right?
How do I create an AWS connection?
It's helping me onboard Hawkeye, right?
It's showing me exactly what I need to do.
I can ask, you know,
because it's connected
to my AWSCLI, I can ask
it to create this role
that Hawkeye needs, right?
So I can do the whole
workflow right here, onboard,
set up my project that
basically takes the connections
and combines them where you
can also add instructions
because, you know, our
systems are very complex
but Hawkeye can do a tremendous job of
kind of understanding the dependencies,
discovering the
configuration and all that,
but sometimes just like you
onboard a very smart SRE,
you know, that person needs a bit of help,
right, instructions.
So the same thing can
be done with Hawkeye,
where even I use cloud
code to actually create
those instructions sometimes
because I can basically,
you know, use it to create
really great context
for Hawkeye to use in
its investigations, okay?
So, you know, I do all types of work here.
I can summarize all my
past investigations.
I can eventually look at the RCAs
and usually at some point
I need to get back into
the user interface
and I can ask for a
link right here, right?
So I can just jump back into the UI to,
you know, if I prefer a UI, right?
And as I mentioned earlier,
you can always ask follow up
questions on an investigation,
and Hawkeye actually
recommends some questions
and you can set it up so that
it automatically answers that question.
So you think of it as you have
like a budget for investigations
and some alerts you're gonna say
just keep going until
you think you're done.
By default we go, as I
mentioned, one round, right?
Like we go five questions,
one chain of thought,
then we stop, we summarize,
but we can automate the follow up question
or you can have your team
ask that follow up question
in cloud code, in cursor,
in Slack, on Teams,
wherever they want to work.
So that's kind of the vision
for working with an agent
is you have agents working
with other agents through MCV,
you have people working with agents
without necessarily using a tool, right?
I'm on Slack, I'm just
talking to this agent,
it's providing me useful information,
I'm asking for follow up questions.
I'm not really using a new tool,
there's something in the
background that's helping me
and that's kind of the vision
that we have for agentic SREs.
You know, there's a lot of
things that SREs need to do
and we're connected to
so many other teams,
DBAs, et cetera.
We're gonna have a lot of different agents
doing all these pieces of the work
and I think, you know,
a great model is to use
a coding agent as your main interface
where you're basically
interacting with all
these different agents
that help you do your job.
We have a lot of traction in this space
and a lot of excitement around this.
And we are also just launched yesterday,
I don't know if you saw the news,
but we have now launched
self-service onboarding.
So you can go to your AWS
account in the Marketplace
and say I want to start using Hawkeye
and we will automatically provision
a SaaS instance of Hawkeye for you
and you will get a two week trial
and you're up and running
within five minutes,
you can start using Hawkeye
and you pay as you go.
So no commitment, just
go to the AWS console,
go to your Marketplace,
find NeuBird there,
and start using it right away.
And so within 15, 20 minutes
you'll be actually running
deep analysis on your alerts
and you can configure your AWS CloudWatch,
you can configure Datadog, Dynatrace,
we have Grafana as well available there.
For enterprise customers we
go and do private offers.
We deploy in your VPC, we use your LLMs,
we can connect to any
observability tool of your choice,
any incident management
tools of your choice,
but for those that just want
to get started self-service,
they can just simply connect
and get started right away
with our SaaS offering.
So again, we're basically connecting
to everything under the sun.
You'll see a lot of different
solutions out there.
People claiming they have AISRE,
Amazon just launched theirs yesterday.
We're excited to have Amazon also join
the efforts to help SREs.
What you'll find is a lot
of them are kind of siloed.
So you've got one for AWS
CloudWatch, one for Datadog,
they have their Bits AI,
you have one, Dynatrace have their agent.
We believe that, you know,
most organizations have
more than one source of data
and our agent goes across all that.
So a lot of people have, you know,
maybe they use CloudWatch for
some of the Amazon services,
they use Prometheus to monitor
the metrics for Kubernetes,
they use Datadog for this
other service, right?
It's a patchwork usually,
unless you're super consolidated
and even if you're consolidated, you know,
most of these agents are limited
like we can actually look at configs,
we can use Coop Cuddle,
we can bring in MCP servers
if you have your own data
that you want to provide.
So we believe that you need
a kind of a Swiss Army knife
that's orchestrating
your incident response
across all these tools to help you along
and make sure that you look like this guy,
not the guy we saw earlier.
Super happy now you're
just having a great time
working with your coding
agent and Hawkeye.
So let me skip through some of this.
I just want to leave you here.
I have one minute, 18 seconds.
I think I'm gonna finish early,
but I really encourage
you to go and onboard,
start here and sign up and just try it
and tell us what you
think we would, you know,
we're the first to be bold enough to
open this up publicly
for everybody to use,
which shows you just the
maturity of our offering
where we're confident this
is gonna work for you.
So please just take advantage of it.
It's free to get started.
You're gonna have two weeks
of free investigations
and you're just gonna pay as you go,
so it's very no commitment.
Just go consume it through
the Amazon Marketplace
and we would love to
just hear your feedback.
So we're at booth 1219 if you want
to learn more we're there,
we've got a cafe,
but behind the Datadog slide where
a lot of us are hanging out
and you'll see the NeuBird branding there
and come and see us and would
love to speak to you about
what your vision is and how
we can help you get there.
Thank you very much.
Enjoy the show.